عدلات اقل الاكتئاب سجلتها السعوديه خلال
العام الماضي مقارنه بعام الجائع 20 20
حيث كشف المركز الوطني لتعزيز الصحه
النفسيه عن انخفاض معدل الاكتئاب من
13.8% الى 12.7 من 10%
اكد مركز تعزيز الصحه النفسيه في السعوديه
ان مؤشر القلق ارتفع بشكل طفيف مقارنه
بالعامدات وفقا لاحدث الدراسات فان الاناث
معرضات بشكل اكبر لاصابه باعراض القلق
العام منها عند الرجال وحاول اسباب ارتفاع
معدل الاكتئاب اوضح المركزه انخفاض معدل
الداخل الى اقل من خمسه الاف ريال سعودي
بالاضافه الى ممارسه العاده التدخين
بمختلف انواعه من الاسباب الرئيسيه
انا خالد كيف حالك
الدكتوره حياك الله مع الدكتوره لمياء
ابراهيم الكاتبه الصحفيه حياك الله دكتوره
راقبك راقب حركات جسدك هل فيها علامات
اكتئاب
ما شاء الله
واحد تقريبا
هل هذا الانخفاض المطمئن ولا يبعث على
القلق بشكل اكبر
طيب بشكل عام احنا
تطورت اليه المسح سواء كانت من ناحيه
الاكتئاب او حتى القلق تطور الوعي بالنسبه
للناس حتى انهم بيعرفوا انه عندهم مشاكل
ترتبط بالقلق الاطفال نفسهم لا هذه صار
عندهم وعي انهم يذهبون باطفالهم الى
الاخصائي النفسي او المرشد النفسي او طبيب
الاسره حتى انهم يستشيروا في وضع ابنائهم
وبالتالي يمكن تشخيص القلق او الاكتئاب في
او الامراض النفسيه بشكل عام تشخيصها بشكل
اسرع الضغوط اللي كانت تمر على الناس سواء
كانت في سبب او حتى ما بعد الجائحه قلق
المكان
والصراعات على المكانه قلق الاستحقاقيه
وتقدير الذات قلق حتى لما انه الشكل همم
الظروف بشكل عام لما تكلمت حتى على المراه
يعني حتى من ناحيه مثلا السوشيال ميديا
وتاثير السوشيال ميديا والتنافسيه هذه
زياده همم يعني احد الاسباب انه زادت
المقارنه يعني سابقا كان الناس تقارن
نفسها بمحيطها المباشر حاليا تقدر تقارن
نفسها بالعالم كله بشكل عام لماذا هذا
الشخص عندي وان هذا الشخص وانا ما عندي
همم البطاله لها دور
بنتكلم عن التضخم وارتفاع الاسعار
بين الناس التي تعيش في المدن وبين الناس
تعيش في القرى او الهجر او بالناس اللي
تعيش في المناطق المائيه والمناطق الجبليه
هنالك عوامل كثيره ولكن احد الاسباب الى
هذه المساله وتطور اليه الماس والوصول الى
فئه كبيره من المجتمع نحن لا نتكلم عن
التشخيص يعني حتى لو احنا نتكلم عن
التشخيص لها معايير معينه تكلم ماذا بعد
التشخيص ماذا بعد هذه العلاقات
الان كيف انا اعرف انه انا عندي اكتئاب
ولا لا اليوم الملاحظ انه في كثير من
الصفحات والمواقع وغيره تضع اسئله معينه
الاجابه عليها ممكن تحطنا في درجه من
درجات الاكتئاب خفيف متوسط حاد ما ادري
ايش يعني فبالتالي هل يمكن الركوب
الاسئله اللي ممكن من خلالها احدد انه انا
مريض ولا لا بالاكتئاب ومتى يكون خطر وكيف
ممكن نتعامل معاه بشكل اكتئاب مرض
نفسيز اورسيكل لما يدخل في مرحله الاضطراب
يعني ممكن ان يكون احباط حاله مؤقته من اي
سبب من الاسباب لما يتطور الموضوع ان يكون
اكثر تقريبا من سته اشهر يعني بحاله مزمنه
يمكن ثلاث مرات في الاسبوع دائما الانسان
يكون عنده فكره معينه لها يعني لتشخيص
الاكتئاب وكذلك هي تشخيص القلق لما تطول
على فتره على سته اشهر من الانسان دائما
بيكون في حاله انه همم حزين همم
يميل الى البكاء همم الاشياء اللي تمتعوا
في السابق لا تمتعوا في الوقت الراهن تظهر
على ربما اعراض جسديه مختلفه منها لا بد
ان يذهب الى الطبيب الذي يستطيع من خلال
الاسئله ومن خلال تشخيص الاعراض ان يصل
الى همم تقريب التجهيز وليس التشخيص
النهائي حتى يتاكد هل ما في هذه اعراض هي
نفسيه او لربما تخفي اثار عضويه او اسباب
عضويه هنالك اسباب عضويه تسبب ايضا اعراض
الاكتئاب من ضمنها انخفاض هرمون الغده
الدرقيه من ضمنها كذلك تغير بعض الهرمونات
بشكل عام من ضمنها طبعا الضغوط العصبيه
الضغوط النفسيه لاسباب او مشاكل اسريه او
اي مشاكل مهنيه فلهذا الامر التشخيص لن
ندعي ندعه الى الطبيب حتى الان اجتهد في
ذلك نعم
اصلا ممكن يتسلى فيها انا اعتبرها تسليه
هي يعني جزء من التشخيص السايكو مدريد
ولكن لا يعتمد عليها بشكل نهائي خصوصا انه
الاكتئاب قد لا يكون هو يعني مرض فقط نفس
نفسي
لكن غير ذلك لابد ان نشخص المريض او نتاكد
من عدم وجود مسببات لمرض الاكتئاب مثل
هذاك الاسباب اللي هرمونيه الاسباب
المهنيه هذه هذه دور مثلا طبيب الاسره
طبيب الاسره ينظر الى المريض بشكل شامل
وبالتالي يشخص الاكتئاب لكن ايوه لكن ارجع
اقول احنا هذا الدور هذا الدور العيادات
النفسيه وبما فيها طبعا مراكز الرعايه
الاوليه مزوده بعيادات نفسيه تقريبا عندنا
يعني
حياته تتاثر
باحداث مستقبليه لم تحصل بدات اني تتاثر
حياته انه بي دائما عصبي ولما بيجلس مع
اهلها وبيخسر علاقاتها مع اهله مع عمله مع
اصدقاءها يعني جوده حياته تاثرت فهنا
يحتاج الى المساعده لا اذا هو يروح معالج
شعبي
اذا كان يرى ان يذهب الى شيخ او يذهب الى
معالج نفسي امشي لا يكوي ولا يضر لكن اذا
كان يعتقد انه
لجا الى اي طريقه ماعدا طبعا احنا ما ننصح
فيه ان لا يتوجه الى الادويه والعقاقير
والمخدرات ولا الكحول هذا ولا التدخين هذا
ما ينصح فيه يعني يتجنب ذلك ولا انه ايضا
يتحول لكريفنج للفوت يعني مرحله اللي هو
الحزن وتعويض الحزن بتناول الطعام
وبالتالي يزداد الوزن وهذه ايضا هذه
الاشياء التي يمكن تؤثر على المراه خصوصا
مع الاضطرابات الهرمونيات وتبدا بالاكل
الزياده يزيد وزنها زياده
اكتئاب عندها والقلق وتدخل في دوامه
هو يقول انه في انخفاض في معدل الاكتئاب
ممكن ارتفاع في مؤشر القلق العلاقه بينهما
همم طبيعيه ولا المفروض يكون
للخفاض مع انخفاض
وهل في فرق بين القلقاس
يرتبط بالاكتئاب ولكن لربما ادوات التشخيص
تغيرت يعني ما كان يشخص انه اكتئاب هو
تبين انه خلق انا كانت عندي حاله 20 سنه
يكتب في ملفها ان هي عندها اكتئاب لما شخص
اختها وفق لك رايه
ظهر ان عندها اجتماعي وليس اكتئاب يعني هي
تعتبر من امراض القلب ولما غيرت العلاج
لها للرهاب الاجتماعي تحسنت وهي 20 سنه
كانت تكتب اكتئاب وكل ما تذهب الى الطبيب
بيعالجها بنفس ادويه الاكتئاب فلهذا
الموضوع
لا ارغب بالمرضى ان يجتهدون بانفسهم في
التشخيص وفي العلاج هذا اللي نحتاجه فعلا
في تعزيز الصحه النفسيه احتاج الى الوعي
تحتاج الى ان تكون هنالك عيادات الصحه
النفسيه في الرعايه الصحيه الاوليه لانها
اسهل اسهل المريض يذهب الى الحي الى طبيبه
الذي تعود ان يتكلم معه
والطبيب انه بيشخصصه انك هل انت تحتاج الى
المساعده لربما المساعده السلوكيه ما
يحتاج ان يصل الى المرحله الدوائيه لربما
هو قناعاته الدينيه والروحانيه حسن حالتي
نحن ضد اي نوع من انواع العلاج ما عدا اذا
الناس
حتى تتاكد من حاله الصحه والنفسيه شكرا لك
تحكم كثير